sexually i mean
this is one the one disappeared
let's spin the wheel
i uh
i hate that we're doing a spinning of
the wheel for two numbers
flip a coin
[Laughter]
but good to be here
abortion laws
you know roe versus wade was passed in
uh 1976
uh ergo it is uh illegal to kill your
babies
i think we just need to be honest with
these conservatives and just be like yes
we want to kill babies there's nothing
wrong with that
you can't just let every baby live
like these conservatives they treat
their [ __ ] cattle but better than
they treat their [ __ ] human beings
like if the cows like dying they'll just
put him out of his misery because that's
like an important like [ __ ] [ __ ] up
cow with 17 legs
but like when a human being turns out
like you know like
gay or
kill those [ __ ] gay babies
that's how we get them on board
if we if we can find out which babies
are gay will you be on board with
abortions
we have a gaydar for a sonogram monogram
whatever
and find out which ones will vote for
biden
you're saying you want this baby to live
and vote for biden
[ __ ] it you hate america you don't want
to kill this baby
um you know abortion laws
uh you know should we really have laws
telling us who we can and can't kill
whatever happened to freedom
we should be able to decide who dies who
lives
you know i love i love a good abortion
they stop doing the coat hanger thing i
think it's like a
[Music]
this is how i think abortions go down
ah the woman comes in and he's like oh
my god i just had sex and it's like so
stupid i have a baby now this sucks i'm
like okay uh hop on the table and then
they uh
and then they like put a needle in and
then just put it fill it with like
cyclone b or
[Music]
the baby it's like a concentration camp
in there
[Music]
the shower head has 11 holes
so even if it has fingers it can't cover
it all up
and then the baby dies
uh and then the girl's like thank you so
much
i'm gonna palazzo there
can we party
and then you know the world goes around
more drinks are bought um
ubers are paid for the economy
functions
[Music]
book of xanax
uh xanax is great uh little zany it's
what rappers do to be cool
um it used to be for white women and now
uh
black people are doing it and as usual
they're doing it way better than white
people are
they made it [ __ ] awesome it used to
be for housewives to take and forget
that they had a cake in the oven
now black people are doing it and
they're writing amazing songs
they're buying lamborghinis
they're dancing
what a great race
let's see why you could slave them
got to keep them down now we're even
[ __ ] no i uh i love being asian
because i'm a neutral third party i can
say that
uh slavery net good net positive i mean
how else are you gonna kanye over
we need a here bit of slavery we can't
just have everyone you know doing what
they want we need
the middle passage to weed out the week
um
hello zannies i've never actually done
them i would uh i would be down it just
seems like a little artificial a little
like uh you know like
shitty acid like sad acid
acid that
you know
makes you like think about things
um xanax xannies um
i love it uh xanax
um it's a cool word it's like xerox
maybe uh you know maybe that's a thing
it's a rare word that starts with x you
know it's hard to figure out
uh how to say it sometimes you know it's
like maybe it's like an aztec god
xanax and xylitol
i love the good x
um i have an x and
she
she actually uh i i blocked her before
she could block me
i could sense a coming it's like who's
gonna be the one to block who and now i
blocked her first so i feel
a little good you know
but it was really a hurtful thing and
really no one wins we both get hurt and
now i have
stds
um but uh yeah it's cool i love my ex
she's in san antonio uh [ __ ] san antonio
much of uh you know loose women there um
she needs a little xanax i think xanax
uh is good for white women it uh sort of
mellows them out and keeps them from
being karen's
uh if you have enough xanax you don't go
to like a customer service person it
would be like listen here [ __ ]
you're just like what
okay
it makes white women tolerable and black
people are awesome
all right let's do another one
[Music]
hopefully it's not one that i wrote
the numbers fell but i can remember
botox
jesus christ so many medical procedures
uh it's probably written by nausea she's
probably
squirting botox back there
she can't
she probably pees on botox she probably
squirts botox from her tits
um i love botox i don't think it's not
good for you uh you can always tell
it looks a little shiny a little uh
clean looks like the dry erase board on
the skin
i think there has to be a better way
it's like
what was to common doing you know get
some mummy
fluid in you you know
botox
i um i think plastic surgery there's
some good ones i just don't think the
skin stuff is good i don't think they've
figured out skin yet
um like if you want to shave down your
nose i can't even tell uh an incognito
if you want to shave down your jaw you
know it can be a woman
but botox i don't think it's it's there
um
botox i think is great i know this girl
who does botox her name is christy vera
and uh she's like trying to take back
botox it's like yeah we do botox now
what's the thing it's like just
eat kale and
exercise
you don't have to [ __ ] do botox like
maybe like if you're old you're just old
you know just you're just old now and
maybe we shouldn't just have everyone
trying to be young and maybe we should
respect our elders
and then they won't be getting botox
hedonistic individualism that uh will be
the doubtful of your civilization and
asian people will rule the earth
because we uh we actually do a lot of
plastic surgeries
i don't know what i'm saying but um
botox i think you should try it um
[Music]
i uh i think you have to do it over and
over again it's like [ __ ]
multivitamins it's like not worth it
it's too much work you have to put it
under your skin
it's just
it's just a lot but it talks
music
let's get to a lot of these
uh one
this is one
uh this one is a lot of drawings a woman
made this way too artistic for a man
friends with benefits or option b
finger popping [ __ ] or
options sex addiction this is just like
a vibe someone
watched euphoria and then
made it into a note card what the [ __ ]
is this
someone is uh on xanax and botox
friends with benefits or option b i
don't know what option b is is that anal
is a
plan b
so friends with benefits or plan b i
would say both and dirty more
if you're gonna have friends with
benefits please take plan b
every day
i think friends with benefits is cool
you know you don't have to like have a
monogamous relationship you can just
play the field and just
have like a bunch of people you know get
to know them and amalgamate them into
one giant mass of humanity
and then you can uh average out and just
like you know this people are like this
and you can explore humanity through
your genitals
option b i don't know finger popping
[ __ ] so it's like an [ __ ] that
can pop a finger
oh finger okay [ __ ] virginity i kind
of like my interpretation better
uh
it's like a chinese finger trap that's
in an [ __ ]
you try to pull your finger out it just
pops it
it's the new way to do chiropractics
your head in my ass
and then i'll do a key goal and
you'll get relief
but apparently this means
an [ __ ] that is virginal and then a
lady sticks her finger inside of it
which i think is a very much needed in
our society i think if everyone every
man
men
got their [ __ ] fingered maybe putin
would have invaded ukraine
maybe uh
biden would uh [ __ ] wake up
we just need more fingers and [ __ ]
ladies get to work start fingering
[ __ ]
be like a man about it just be really
creepy start drugging people and
get to work
or option c sex addiction oh okay
friends with benefits or fingerprint
poppin [ __ ] or sex addiction i don't
i don't understand who the [ __ ] this is
this is like a a.i wrote this i don't
think you're a human
doubting your humanity
uh sex addiction
um i think that's called the procreation
it's kind of what we need to do to you
know like get the next generation
it's like uh food addiction yeah
everyone just food every day um i don't
think that it's helpful this uh you know
uh way of categorizing people with
mental illnesses and being like dsm and
like oh you are bipolar is schizophrenic
it's just like just tell them that
they're an artist and that painting
it's like um you know sex addiction and
what do we have to call it addiction we
all want sex i think we should have more
sex um
especially with me
i love good sex
i'm kind of addicted to sex i masturbate
uh to online pornography about three or
four times a day
thank you who said that she hates sex
don't kick shame me my kink
touching myself a lot
um but yeah i mean i'm 32 and i'm just
jerking off like i'm 29 21.
and it's just it's just crazy because
like you know i'm really good at it
sometimes like uh i'll be having sex and
i'll have to pull out and jerk off
and
that's fine
it's not fine says my dad
well maybe you could show me your ways
maybe i could finger pop your [ __ ]
but yeah i love i love jerking off and
i'm not ashamed of it i am a little bit
um
but i uh i just did it before i came
here so [ __ ] you guys you're
experiencing post-nut masturbation
energy right now vicariously through
um i me
masturbating and
i'm gonna do it again in the green room
right now
i've been doing it this whole time
my name is hans thank you
[Applause]
masturbation skills
you